so when I was 18 years old I went to
skydiving for the very first time and
this was in Ohio and it was oh really
this is before they had tandem jumping
and somebody on your back guiding you
down and I had to I had to jump with a
static line like a rope attached to the
airplane floor and the whole thing was
shoddy the airplane was held together
with like duct tape and change it was
really really hysterical and the men and
I kind of let go with a plane and jumped
out of the plane I flew out of my body
like I my consciousness was like 25 feet
away and I was staring back at my body
and what was actually even stranger
about the whole thing is as I was doing
it I had started to tip back my back was
in an awkward angle and I realized when
the shoot was going to catch I was going
to get whiplash unless I totally relaxed
all my muscles so my extra corporal self
looked at this and said okay you got to
relax otherwise you're gonna end up in
the hospital and I did in the minute the
chute caught I popped back into my body
so what the hell is going on there right
out-of-body experiences are mystical
experiences now there are also fairly
common mystical experiences if you put
out a body and near-death experiences
together and they're sort of we've now
discovered they're sort of out-of-body
experiences tend to lead into near-death
experiences but if you lump them as a
cat category according to Gallup ten to
twenty percent of all Americans have had
this experience so it's very common
right one out of five of us have had
this experience yet it's very very
mystical what's interesting is over the
past twenty five years really kind of
starting I think in the early 90s as
brain imaging technology kind of came up
to speed for the first time we started
to really poke at what are these
experiences we now know what causes
out-of-body experiences we have some
very good ideas about what causes
near-death experiences in fact if you go
through the spiritual Canon whether
you're talking about cosmic unity that
feeling of oneness with everything or
glossolalia speaking in tongues trance
States meditative states flow States
psychedelic experiences write all these
things on all these altered states of
consciousness that we've called
spiritual depending on our cultures
right over years are now known as the
product of kind of standard biology and
that's where we
our today and that's really interesting
but let's consider Michael Persinger
work right he's a neuroscientist at
Laurentian University he invented
something called the so-called God
helmet now the god helmet directs a weak
electromagnetic pulse basically creates
a weak electromagnetic field around the
right temporal lobe now the right
temporal lobe is actually one of the
things that causes out-of-body
experiences if you've stimulated if you
becomes hyperactive it can dislocate the
self so over a thousand people have
warned Michael person there's god helmet
right eighty percent of them report
feeling a sensed presence in the room
the feeling that there's something or
someone a god a demon and Angel a ghost
in the room with them other people have
reported out a body experiences a couple
people have reported nothing at all but
as a general rule most people experience
something so that's technology that's
here today it already exists there are
versions of that technology that are
available to consumers you can get
online and you can buy I think it's
called the Shakti something you can buy
a version of the god helmet all right
where it gets really strange is
Persinger is trying to incorporate the
god helmet into virtual reality
technologies possibly inside of a game
so think about this for a second eighty
million Americans right now call
themselves spiritual but not religious
which means they're searching for a
direct experience of the numinous right
they want some kind of mystical
experience in their own lives they want
to see it for themselves they think
there's something out that they're
searching they believe in it they want
that well pretty soon that experience is
going to be available by a video game
and once again that changes everything
right these are the most sacred rare
experiences in the history of the world
and if you think about it right if you
think about what the goddammit produces
which is a feeling of a ghost or a God
in the room all of our religions
basically begin with somebody bumping
into a god right that's where religion
comes from as a general rule there are
other things that happen but as a
general that's where religion comes from
well pretty soon that very experience
right the very foundational experience
is that it's birthed all or most of the
world's religion it's going to be
available to anybody at scale maybe in
your phone maybe in a video game you
play in your computer it's a crazy crazy
crazy idea and will forever change the
nature of religion on this planet